[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna büchs herzlich willkommen an
diesem freitag mit sport von norbert
lehmann
und den wichtigsten themen des tages
schwere waffen für die ukraine der
kanzler erklärt sein zögern es dürfe
keinen atomkrieg geben sagt er eine
militärische konfrontation mit russland
wolle er unbedingt vermeiden
russland nennt das ziel der laufenden
offensive der don was im osten und der
gesamte süden der ukraine sollen erobert
werden in mario pohl werden massengräber
ausgehoben
aus der nordsee statt aus russland eine
bohrplattform soll vor borkum erdgas
fördern umweltschützer und inselbewohner
sind dagegen
nachdem die kritik an ihm nicht abreißt
hat sich kanzler scholz jetzt nochmal
genauer zu seiner zurückhaltung bei der
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
geäußert er tue alles um eine eskalation
zu verhindern die zu einem dritten
weltkrieg führen könne sagte scholz
waffenlieferungen auch thema bei der
baltikum reise von bundesaußenminister
in bernburg heute besuchen litauen
ganzen berichtet
deutschland führt den nato gefechts
verband dort an schon kurz vor
kriegsbeginn wurde er aufgestockt auf
rund 1600 kräfte 1000 davon deutsche zu
einer weiteren aufstockung beim nato
gipfel ende juni sei deutschland bereit
so baerbock heute der einsatz hier
garantiere europa sicherheit mit blick
auf die ukraine werde man zudem den
druck auf russland weiter erhöhen auch
mit noch schärferen sanktionen
deutschland hat hier eine besondere
verantwortungsvolle rolle bis die
ukraine wieder frei und sicher ist ein
waffenstillstand um jeden preis kann es
nicht geben ein diktat frieden werden
wir nicht akzeptieren
allein die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
entscheiden über ihre zukunft so ähnlich
äußerte sich kanzler scholz im spiegel
zu kiews wunsch fortdauern schweres
bundeswehr gerät zu bekommen das dann
nach und nach ersetzt werde sagte er
dagegen spreche die notwendigkeit das
bündnisgebiet jederzeit verteidigen zu
können das ist eine schwierige abwägung
die wir gemeinsam mit unseren partnern
ständig treffen müssen denn die
bedrohungen des nato gebiets durch
russland besteht ja vor dass putin atome
drohe für den fall dass deutschland
panzerlieferung bestätigte scholzen
nicht zitat es gibt kein lehrbuch für
diese situation indem man nachlesen
könnte ab welchem punkt wir als
kriegspartei wahrgenommen werden cdu csu
bekräftigten derweil ihr vorhaben
nächste woche im bundestag einen antrag
einzubringen für die lieferung schwerer
waffen da es hierfür eine
überparteiliche mehrheit gebe kritik von
der spd was wir nicht tun sollten ist
hier in politisch parteitaktische spiele
zu spielen parteitaktisch versuchen
profit zu schlagen aus einer brutalen
situation wie sie grad in der ukraine
ist nein es geht um die sache dort
werden ein mensch frauen vergewaltigt
zivilisten ermordet gefoltert es ist
nicht nur ein rechtswidriger
angriffskrieg es ist ein
zivilisationsbruch sondergleichen und
der muss gestoppt werden und er kann
sowie russland ihnen führt nur mit
schweren waffen gestoppt werden der
gestern von der bundesregierung
angekündigte ringtausch von panzern mit
slowenien reichen nicht ähnlich sieht es
die jüngst schon sehr kritische
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
von der fdp diese idee hatten meine
kolleginnen und kollegen im ausschuss
bereits vor drei wochen aber wir müssen
darüber hinaus schauen gibt es trotzdem
noch mehr was wir möglicherweise liefern
können kommt es zum von der union
geplanten antrag samt namentlicher
abstimmung wird es die nächste
bewährungsprobe für die ampel
er lassen wir das ganze mal einschätzen
von theo koll kann die abstimmung für
kanzler scholz politisch gefährlich
werden
nun sie ist in jedem fall momentan nicht
kalkulierbar das parlament ist noch in
der osterpause und damit ist doch kein
klares mehrheits bild erkennbar aber
hinter die anderen bei der union dass
die grünen und die fdp mehrheitlich oder
sogar geschlossen für die lieferung
schwerer waffen stimmen würde davon
glaube ich getrost in fragezeichen
setzen natürlich gibt es sehr präsent
die kritiker der regierungslinie und
auch der designierte generalsekretär der
fdp macht jetzt druck aber die ampel
linie wird ja im bundessicherheitsrat
von allen drei parteiführungen
mitgetragen und die ampel parteien haben
fast 100 stimmen mehr als die opposition
es müsste also viele abweichender ampel
stimmen für den unionsantrag geben
interessant dürfte sein wie sich die fdp
auf ihrem morgigen parteitag verhält und
in jedem fall hat die ganze debatte den
kanzler beschädigt die geheimniskrämerei
über die lieferungen die
unterschiedlichen begründungen warum was
nicht geht vielen kritikern fehlt es
schlicht an einer raumfüllenden kanzler
präsenz die in einer solchen krise nötig
wäre dankeschön theo koll und
was genau andere nato staaten tun zur
unterstützung der ukraine im kampf gegen
die russische offensive und welche
waffen sie liefern einen überblick
darüber finden sie bei zdf reutte und in
der zdf-reihe
seine angriffe setzt russland
währenddessen mit unerbittlicher härte
fort ein befehlshaber der russischen
streitkräfte nannte heute das ziel der
zweiten phase des militäreinsatzes
nämlich die vollständige kontrolle über
den don was im osten der ukraine und
über den kompletten süden bis zur
republik moldau ein ziel für das die
menschen in den von moskau beanspruchten
gebieten bitter bezahlen
acht wochen gewalt acht wochen
zerstörung acht wochen tod und leid der
krieg hat kleine städtchen in lehre
ruinen kulissen verwandelt das ist der
ort wo wiesen umkämpften osten direkt an
der aktuellen frontlinie die meisten
bewohner sind geflohen eine handvoll
gestrandete hat einen letzten
rückzugsort gefunden im palast der
kulturen im keller
irgendwann nach zwei wochen krieg musste
ich aus der wohnung raus das dach kaputt
es regnete rein die wände waren feucht
in so einem haus kammer nicht bleiben
kein gas kein licht kein wasser
vom leid der menschen ist im russischen
staatsfernsehen nichts zu entdecken auf
dem weg zum feind werden hier die panzer
begeistert eskortiert und der front
gelingt dann der durchbruch
die waffen des westens werden zur beute
dazu passen auch die russischen
meldungen aus mario pohl in der
strategisch wichtigen metropole mit den
gigantischen us auf stahlwerk gab es
eine martialisch inszenierte siegerpose
tschetschenische kämpfer sie hätten die
stadt den hafen und auch das stahlwerk
erobert doch die militärische lage ist
unverändert in den tiefen des
geschundenen industriekomplexes harren
weiter zivilisten und ukrainische
kämpfer aus die ultra nationale azoff
brigade gibt nicht auf
solange wir hier sind es mario pohl
unter ukrainischer kontrolle mariupol
wird immer ukrainisch sein egal was sie
sagen die kämpfe gehen weiter sinnlos zu
kommentieren was russische faschisten
sagen sie lügen immer
jenseits aller propaganda tobt
unbarmherzig der krieg ohne klare
informationen etwa inhuman hier brennt
an krankenhaus getroffen von russischen
granaten twittern augenzeugen
uno-vertreter sammeln seit kriegsbeginn
alle hinweise auf mutmaßliche verbrechen
heute ein ernüchterndes zwischenfazit
die russische armee hat bewohnte gebiete
geschossen und bombardiert zivilisten
getötet krankenhäusern schulen zerstört
taten die sich als kriegsverbrechen
erweisen können
58 tage krieg nun endet in der ukraine
und in russland die karwoche ein
orthodoxes osterfest im zeichen der
gewalt
und in der ukraine ist unser reporter
dominic löschmeister dominik warum
scheitert es ständig diese
zivilbevölkerung aus mario pohl
herauszubekommen durch flucht korridore
die straßen seien nicht sicher sagt die
ukrainische regierung auch heute keine
flucht korridore das problem ist mario
pohl ist von den russischen truppen
umzingelt das heißt wenn die busse rein
und raus wollen müssen sie durch
checkpoints diese fahrt kann tage dauern
hinzu kommt dass die ukrainische seite
den großen vorwirft diese busse zu
beschießen moskau widerspricht dem
derzeit ist es so dass die menschen in
der stadt auch die schwierigkeit haben
zu diesen bussen zu kommen denn wenn das
beschuss gibt müsste man den keller
verlassen oder den bunker verlassen das
sind frauen und kinder und das ist eine
zusätzliche gefahren wir hatten in der
vergangenheit auch immer wieder
zivilisten die gestorben sind durch
beschuss weil sie zu diesen bussen auch
wollten moskau hat jetzt noch einmal für
diese stahlwerk eine feuerpause
angeboten wenn die ukraine sicher geben
doch danach sieht es nicht aus aus der
ukraine dominik löschmeister dankeschön
deutschland will ja wegen des ukraine
krieges möglichst schnell ersatz für
russische gaslieferung finden vor der
insel borkum in der nordsee bietet sich
so eine alternative im grenzgebiet mit
den niederlanden schlummern 60
milliarden kubikmeter gas zum vergleich
deutschland verbraucht derzeit 90
milliarden pro jahr wovon nur etwa fünf
milliarden aus eigener förderung kommen
umweltverbände sind gegen die
erschließung des neuen feldes auch wegen
der nähe zum naturpark wattenmeer aber
niedersachsen hat jetzt grünes licht
gegeben peter kunz berichtet der blick
ins weite meer hier auf der nordseeinsel
borkum könnte künftig bei gutem wetter
an einer gasplattform hängen bleiben 20
kilometer vor dem ferien strand soll sie
stehen da würde ich hier keinen urlaub
mehr machen mit tut's weh dass dann die
ganze umwelt wieder hier in
mitleidenschaft gezogen ist der
nationalpark wattenmeer die umwelt die
urlauber aus vielen gründen waren die
gas bohrpläne vor borkum eigentlich
begraben wurden der ukraine krieg hat
sie wieder nach oben geschwemmt vor dem
hintergrund der völlig veränderten
geopolitischen realitäten muss die
deutsche energie versorgungssicherheit
neu gedacht ja wir sind natürlich
enttäuscht und wir reden von
erdbebengefahr von senkungen aber auch
von verschmutzung des wassers was dann
wirklich die strömung her getragen wird
diese gründe sind nach wie vor da
nordsee gas spezialisten dafür sitzen in
den niederlanden das ist ein planungs
video der firma die als partner des
landes niedersachsen das
grenzüberschreitende gasreserve vor
borkum ausbeuten soll gebohrt wird von
niederländischen hoheitsgewässern
richtung insel ungefährlich für mensch
und natur beteuert der chef wir werden
mit striktesten deutschen und
niederländischen umwelt standards
produzieren das environment zustande wir
brauchen dieses gasfeld nicht erstens
ist es kontraproduktiv für den
klimaschutz jetzt wieder in die
gasförderung einzusteigen zweitens liegt
das feld am rande des weltnaturerbes
wattenmeer
stattdessen sollten wir jetzt einsteigen
in energiesparen gas vom ferienort für
eine russland unabhängige versorgung
bleibt das ein kleiner baustein während
unsere energie sorgen die aussicht auf
borkum sowieso schon verändert haben
nach einer reihe von skandalen muss
sachsens innenminister roland wöller von
der cdu nun seinen hut nehmen es hatte
vorwürfe von vetternwirtschaft gegeben
und immer neue vorfälle bei der
sächsischen polizei neuer innenminister
soll der derzeitige chef des bundesamtes
für bevölkerungsschutz und langjährige
cdu bundestagsabgeordnete armin schuster
werden cornelia schiemenz und franziska
wunderlich über die entlassung verlass
paukenschlag in dresden der
ministerpräsident schmeißt seinen
innenminister hochkant aus dem abend
gerade mal drei minuten nahm sich
michael kretschmer heute dafür zeit
meine einschätzung dass es für die
zukunft richtig ist mit einem
personellen neuanfang mit kraft mit
neuen ideen und vor allen dingen mit
mehr und breiterem vertrauen an die
arbeit zu gehen roland wöller seit 2017
sächsischer innenminister
die liste der skandale ist lang
korruptionsvorwürfe bei der leipziger
polizei umstrittene demo einsätze
gestohlene munition zu fall brachte ihn
letztlich der jüngste vorwurf der
vetternwirtschaft
so soll wöller einer früheren
kommilitonen seiner frau einen posten an
der sächsischen polizei hochschule
verschafft haben die polizeigewerkschaft
kritisiert dass es immer weniger
kommunikation gegeben hat immer weniger
transparenz gegeben hat man hat er so
das gefühl gehabt als sich der minister
in seinem büro verschlossenheit und
personalentscheidung getroffen hat die
ja nicht abgesprochen hat roland wöller
war ein enger vertrauter von michael
kretschmer der rausschmiss heute
überfällig meint die opposition wenn
ministerpräsident ist natürlich nicht
ohne blessuren aus der sache raus
gekommen denn er hat sich ja erst es für
hinwil eingesetzt und er hat viel zu
lange an ihm festgehalten neuer
innenminister sachsen soll armin
schuster werden bislang leiter des
bundesamtes für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe offizielle anwendung
am montag
das berliner landgericht hat heute den
parteiausschluss des früheren
brandenburger fdp chefs andreas kalbitz
bestätigt cable seinem eintritt in die
partei 2013 eine frühere mitgliedschaft
in der inzwischen verbotenen
rechtsextremen heimattreuen deutschen
jugend sowie bei den republikanern nicht
angegeben haben die fdp hatte ihm daher
die parteimitgliedschaft entzogen
kalbitz klage dagegen wurde jetzt in
erster instanz abgewiesen
diese messerattacke löste letzten sommer
bundesweit entsetzen aus in einem
kaufhaus in würzburg fragt ein mann nach
einem küchenmesser dann sticht er
wahllos auf menschen in seiner nähe ein
fünf minuten später sind drei frauen tot
neun weitere menschen überleben teils
schwer verletzt seit heute steht er
offenbar psychisch kranke täter aus
somalia vor gericht petra neubauer hat
den prozess verfolgt
der mann aus somalia wirkt zu
prozessauftakt ein wenig verloren
verhandelt wird aus platzgründen in
einem riesigen konferenzzentrum es geht
um mord und versuchten mord aber auch um
eine mögliche schuldunfähigkeit des
mannes das heißt aber nicht dass man auf
die taten die er begangen haben soll
überhaupt nicht reagieren kann sondern
es gibt die möglichkeit der dauerhaften
unterbringung dieses beschuldigten in
einem psychiatrischen krankenhaus
am nachmittag des 25 juni 2021 soll der
beschuldigte ihn und vor einem
würzburger kaufhaus mit einem messer
mehrfach auf andere eingestochen haben
passanten versuchen ihn in schach zu
halten dennoch drei frauen sterben neun
weitere menschen werden verletzt laut
staatsanwaltschaft wollte der mann
seinen willkürlich ausgesuchten opfern
keine chance lassen doch warum das alles
hass oder gegebenfalls religiöse motive
oder ob gegebenenfalls die psychische
erkrankung des beschuldigten in der
rolle gespielt hat muss im rahmen der
hauptverhandlung geklärt werden der mann
der 2015 nach deutschland kam war schon
mehrmals in psychiatrischer behandlung
nimmt medikamente
terroristische hintergründe schließt ein
verteidiger kategorisch aus wir haben
die taten ein er weiß was er
schreckliches leid über viele personen
gebracht hat und er hat auch geäußert
dass stimmen ihn dazu gedrängt haben
also ganz offensichtlich eine psychose
vorherrschend gewesen war ob auch das
gericht dieser sichtweise folgt und eine
womöglich lebenslange unterbringung in
einer geschlossenen einrichtung anordnet
soll in 27 verhandlungstagen entschieden
werden
das jahr 20 21 und das haben wir jetzt
auch amtlich warten europa ein jahr der
extreme das belegen aktuelle klimadaten
der eu so war der sommer der wärmste
seit beginn der aufzeichnungen vor über
40 jahren rekordhitze beispielsweise in
italien
in der folge konnten sich waldbrände
dort aber auch in griechenland und der
türkei rasant
auf der anderen seite gab es im sommer
20 21 aber auch starkregen und
überflutungen wert wir in belgien und in
deutschland
unseren bezirk formel 1 norbert und zum
großen preis der emilia romagna in imola
ein heimspiel also für ferrari die
scuderia ist ja mit zwei siegen in
dieser wm-saison gestartet dank schal
erklärt dem führenden in der
gesamtwertung der musste aber heute nach
einem turbulenten qualifying weltmeister
max verstappen die pole position
überlassen
mal regnet es mal nicht auch weltmeister
max verstappen rutscht von der strecke
der niederländer schon zweimal nicht im
ziel in dieser saison ist minuten vor
dem ende der qualifikation schneller als
der wm-führende charlie le claire der im
ferrari dann die letzte chance sucht dem
aber nach zwei siegen in drei rennen
bislang die zeit fehlt letztlich um
verstappen in der quali noch zu
übertreffen sebastian vettel geht als
guter neunter in das erste von drei
sprintrennen der saison morgen in imola
max verstappen steht da auf startplatz
eins
deutschlands handball frauen haben sich
mit einem rekordsieg für die
europameisterschaft qualifiziert das
team des neuen bundestrainers markus
gaugisch besiegte außenseiter
griechenland klar mit 40 zu 11 so ein
baby wünscht man sich als bundestrainer
eine mannschaft mit biss und spielwitz
war da auf dem platz beim
qualifikationsspiel in mehreren
niederlande gegen insgesamt schwach
agierende griechen die deutschen in weiß
in allen belangen eindeutig überlegen
beste werferinnen waren johanna
stockschläger mit 6 und kapitänin alina
grätzels mit fünf treffern die
einseitige partie allerdings kein
maßstab im testspiel am samstag warten
starken niederländerinnen
überraschungs sieg der bayern im playoff
viertelfinale der basketball euroleague
nach der heimniederlage gelangen den
starken münchner beim fc barcelona im
zweiten von fünf möglichen partien ein
souveränes 90 75 bester werfer bei den
bayern die schon thomas mit 25 punkten
und sechs von sieben verwandte dreier
versuchen
das was im sport dann können wir schauen
noch kurz aufs wetter denn da tut sich
was während es zuletzt besonders im
nordosten trüb war mit etwas regen
scheint morgen dort die sonne und im
süden der würzburger mehr gleich von
katja horneffer das heute schon mal
können sie um 22 uhr sehen mit bettina
schausten schön freitagabend noch
[Musik]
guten abend während über nordeuropa die
hochs dominieren ziehen die tiefs über
südeuropa und kommen uns von süden und
von südwest naja deswegen wird das
wetter zumindest in süddeutschland
wechselhafter das tief über italien
brachte heute aber nicht nur wolken und
regen mit sondern auch saharastaub sie
sehen dass hier an dieser leichten luft
trübung das tief hat aber noch mehr
auswirkungen auf unser wetter denn in
der nacht gibt es dichtere wolken hier
in sachsen und in bayern und da kann es
auch mal leicht regnen in
norddeutschland ist es klar und die
temperaturen sinken hier rund um berlin
auf 3 bis 2 grad milder bleibt es im
westen zum beispiel rhein-main-gebiet
mit neun grad morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 11 grad auf
rügen und 20 grad am rhein und in
norddeutschland strahlt morgen die sonne
meist vom blauen himmel es gibt nur
wenige harmlose wolken und dazu wie der
wind aus östlichen richtungen in
süddeutschland verdichten sich die
wolken mehr und mehr und am nachmittag
kann es dann im südwesten und auch aus
den alpen heraus einige regenschauer und
gewitter geben regen und gewitter weiten
sich dann am sonntag weiter nach norden
aus die küste werden sie wohl nicht
erreichen die temperaturen am sonntag
liegen zwischen 9 und 17 grad guten
abend